♪♪
-And what do you think
your dad does for work?
-Um, he calls
a bunch of people.
-I think he writes e-mails.
Like, boring e-mails.
-I don't really know.
I don't really know.
-He works with computers.
-Make money for people.
-I don't know.
He's just here every day.
I just, like,
don't even care to ask him
because I don't feel
like knowing.
-I'm so bored.
-This is boring.
-Sometimes she gets meetings,
and she eats good food,
like Chinese food, and she gets,
like, so many snacks,
and she -- she has, like,
a cushion seat.
She could just relax all day.
-What does his office look like?
-Looks like a big,
big, big building.
-What's your impression
of your dad at work?
-[ Growls ]
-And how much do you guys
think your dad makes?
-$800.
-$2.
-$100.
-100 million thousand!
-No?
-I don't.
-Jojo, what do you want to be
when you grow up?
-Um...